one of the things that human beings
underestimate dramatically is their
capacity to get great at something if
they're totally immersed in it I was
small and skinny
they still tease me Eddie spaghetti you
know and I'd get bullied at school and I
never retaliated how bad do you want
your goal right now I think there's a
lot of people in the world today because
it's a really nice thing to talk about I
want this this is my outcome this is my
goal like how bad you what you want as
bad as breathing what a sore get a
mentor
[Music]
hey it's Evan Carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back a lack of belief in yourself
you watch these videos because you know
there's something greater inside you you
have Michael Jordan level talent at
something so today this learn from one
of the best ed my let and how to win the
game of life mentor me ed okay let's
kick it off with rule number one get
laser focused one of the things that
human beings underestimate dramatically
is their capacity to get great at
something if they're totally immersed in
it totally laser focused on something
but as I've coached the very high-end
athletes in my life the top
businesspeople and entertainers I can
tell you that most people underestimate
what total obsessive laser-focused
really is and what it looks like because
you are way more powerful than you know
you are if you went crazy psycho
obsessed laser focused on anything even
something you're totally ill-prepared
for humans have an unreal capacity to
get great at things even if they don't
of a natural talent for it if they're
immersed in it and to learn something
and acquire a ton of knowledge in a
short period of time as well Society is
conspiring all the time in our culture
to completely distract you so you never
win to just divert your focus and
attention look over here look at this
shiny thing look at this TV show look at
this sports team worry about what's
going on here in this war and they get
these different things on television in
our phones and in our lives and just get
us distracted so we never get obsessed
we never get laser focused for an
extended period of time
rule number two get in touch with your
gifts when I was small um I was also
really under sized so it's probably the
reasons I lift weights I was always
there every baseball picture I'm the kid
holding a sign in the front right so I
was small and skinny these two teased me
Eddie spaghetti you know and I'd get
bullied at school and I never retaliated
so I had that mix with shyness mixed
with chaos in my home which many people
can relate to and I got to tell you that
the shift for me sports
good for me because it gave me an Al
that I finally found something that I
was pretty good at I think the biggest
shift in our lives the things that makes
us the happiest is that when somebody
helps us identify our natural giftedness
and when I was a little boy when I got a
little bit older they pointed out my
speed so it wasn't my lack of size I was
fast
I was the fast kid right I always wanted
to be fast kid and I got confidence in
baseball doing that when I got into
business I said you know you're intense
when someone points out a gift about you
that you also kind of intuitively know
to be true their link to them is your
intense your passion you won't get out
work you're relentless I when I am those
things and when someone linked those
gifts to me winning now I believed I
could win that's the other way to change
identity is when someone can link your
giftedness to the victory you'll believe
it not like you're great that's general
that's bull but it's something you know
specific like for you right now
you wouldn't brag there's a few things
you know you know what I am good at
these things right I've always been good
at these things it's natural for me and
when someone links that to you winning
like for you for example you're an
unbelievable interviewer you have this
general you you don't need to be the
smartest person in the room because you
probably are most of the time so there's
a confidence know there's a confidence
that allows you to be present when you
interview me and just listen that's
different than anyone who's interviewed
me before and so that's a natural
giftedness for you which is why there's
a part of you that kind of knows I am
pretty you wouldn't say if I am pretty
good at this this is a good program and
so the way we change our identity the
way I changed mine was by getting in
touch with what some of my natural gifts
were and then using them in my career
using them in my life that shifted the
weight right off of me because the
weight was I suck I'm shy I'm small I
have a screwed-up family that's the
weight right the lifting off of the way
it is these are some gifts God gave me
or the universe gave me or that at least
I know I have and I can spend my life
using these gifts now I've got hope now
my identity is changing now my life
takes a different direction also if you
want to have more confidence check out
my 254 series they're free the link to
join are in the description below
the comfortable road will never lead you
to the person you were destined to be
ever in your life
the minute you begin to get external in
your life worrying about what other
people think about you right you vote
you've lost all control you and it never
fills you up a good person in any
endeavor will only take from it what
they think they deserve rule number
three be hungry how bad do you want your
goal right now I think there's a lot of
people in the world today because it's
really nice thing to talk about I want
this this is my outcome this is my goal
like how bad you were do you want as bad
as breathing do you want it as bad as
anything you've ever wanted in your life
and if you calibrate it at the highest
enough levels where I found the people
that are the hungriest they find a way
when you know why you want something
when it's desperation the power of being
desperate is something that most people
avoid they think desperation is a
weakness and I'm here to tell you
desperation is one of the most powerful
emotions you could possibly possess
because when you're desperate you find
reserves and reservoirs of ideas talents
and a strength that you don't know you
have when you find yourself in a
desperate situation so ironically the
one thing most people avoid in their
life hunger which is caused by being
desperate when you're starving
you become desperate think of somebody
who's starving on the street they've got
to how resourceful would you get if your
children were literally starving and you
had to feed them right so the number one
thing we need more than anything to win
is hunger which comes from a state of
desperation yet we're constantly trying
to comfort ourselves in the real world
to avoid the state of being desperate
and I'm telling you that I think you
need to embrace desperation again in
your life like do you want it so bad
that you're desperate for it see in a
fight you show me two people this is why
it's so hard to repeat as a champion in
the fighting game because you show me
someone who's up and coming who's hungry
for that title who's never had it before
who can taste it who knows if they win
that belt their whole life's gonna
change they're gonna be champion of the
world all the endorsements all the money
all their family life all their parents
lives are gonna change you show me
somebody chasing that
hungry for it against someone who's just
trying to hold on to a title and that's
why most of the time the Challenger
beats the champ it's hard to repeat as a
champion because the hunger goes down
just a little bit the greatest athletes
the Kobe's the Bradys the Jordans of
sports have a way of feeding their
hunger all the time and increasing it
what separates them isn't just their
work ethic isn't just their talent
although those things matter isn't just
they practice more what separates them
as they're just hungrier they somehow
find a way as they climb up the ranks
and win championship to get even
hungrier for more where 99% of the
athletes lose just a little bit of their
edge once they get that first
championship that first pro contract
that first big amount of money that
first world championship they just lose
their hunger a little bit and then
there's the elite they get hungrier it
feeds the beast rule number four outwork
everyone I'm addicted to one more and so
I want your mantra going forward to be
one more what does that look like if
we're working out that means when we're
in the gym and we say I'm gonna do five
sets of ten I'm crazy like I'm a psycho
cuz I want to win I want to be somebody
I want to separate I want to compete and
the way I do that isn't with my
giftedness because I wasn't born with a
bunch of gifts and I think gifts are
crap I think for the most part gifted
people struggle in life because things
come easy to them I like the things
haven't come easy for me in my life I
like to have natural talents in every
area and maybe you like that about you
too maybe you've looked at yourself all
your life and thought man I don't have
that natural beauty or that natural
talent or this gift for creativity or
intellect or humor I don't have any of
those things but what I got is that will
outwork you and so at the gym one of the
things I focus on they say it's five
sets of ten when I'm at ten I go one
more BAM 11 if I'm running on the
treadmill it's a 45-minute run I never
finish it 45 I always go one more minute
46 if I'm at the office and I'm supposed
to make 25 phone calls that day when I'm
at the end of the day I always do one
more if I've got meetings I always do
one more my mantra for three decades in
this has been one more and rule number
five the last one before a very special
bonus clip is keep the promises you make
to you people I know that are really
happy are very self-aware in fact the
best entrepreneurs I know are very
self-aware they're aware of their
shortcomings right they want to improve
them they want to get to the next
version of themselves all the time and
so for me self-confidence comes because
I didn't have it and I think anytime you
meet somebody like yourself or myself we
might now appear self-confident it's
because I really had to find tools and
resources because I was so insecure and
shy and introverted so I had to find
techniques and resources to build that
up in me and for me it's very simple
it's the promises that I keep to myself
if I have a habit over and over again to
stack one on top of the other of keeping
promises I make to me not other people
in other words the minute you begin to
get external in your life worrying about
what other people think about you right
you've out you've lost all control you
and it never fills you up and people's
admiration people's gratitude towards
you will never fill you up it's your own
it's your own inside and so for me
self-confidence comes from keeping the
promises I make to myself and the other
part of it is being aware I'm doing it
in other words most people don't give
themselves enough credit all the time
they're very aware of these 20 percent
things and not aware of the 80 right and
that's why the dosage is so important -
you've nailed it it should be 80/20
right because people get addicted to
this I'm not good at this people don't
like this about me I don't feel good
instead of focusing on the 80 and
stacking up wow I did eat what I said I
was going to today I did get up when I
said I was going to I made the amount of
phone calls I treated people in such a
way I promised myself it's not just
doing those things it's rewarding it's
being aware of it and stacking that up
now I have a special bonus tip from Ed
on how to believe in your worth that I
think you can enjoy but before that it's
time for the three-point landing
questions let's go from just watching a
video to taking an action here we go
question number one what promise did you
make to yourself that you need to keep
number two where do you need to start
out working everyone and number three
what's the gift you have that you need
to get
touch with what you allow is what's
going to continue in your life I put out
a post about this several weeks ago it's
hard to accept this but what's happening
in our lives we're allowing it to happen
and to some extent we almost believe we
deserve it because we produce in our
life what we really believe were worth
what we really believe we deserve and it
doesn't it's hard to accept that because
it seems coincidental you know that the
wrong person or life or there was a
business setback or our car broke down
or you know our company went out of
business or whatever it might be one of
your clients just quit and change their
mind and it seems coincidental but you
really truly are getting out of your
life would you believe your worth would
you believe you deserve and you're
allowing it to happen and I'm gonna
challenge you today to stop that stop
allowing it and know that you deserve
better
and if you want to see the one-on-one
interview I did with Ed my let check out
the video right there next to me I think
you'll enjoy it continue to believe and
I'll see you there mr. ed my let how you
doing man I'm good brother how are you
look at that view man can you see it
yeah yeah it comes in and out of focus
but I can see it